Lucia: 我学会了
Lucia: I learned it.
其他人：我看我看一遍就会了
Others: I can do it after watching it once.
其他人：做今天来做肉松小贝鸡蛋
Others: Today, let's make fluffy meat floss cakes.
其他人：这是多少
Others: How many is this?
其他人：这是几个
Others: How many are there?
其他人：6个
Others: Six.
其他人：武林秘籍
Others: Martial arts secret manual.
Tasha: 哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahaha.
其他人：这个本人卖
Others: This is sold by the person himself.
Lucia: 武林秘籍
Lucia: Martial arts secret manual.
Tasha: 对
Tasha: Yes.
其他人：准备找他
Others: Ready to find him.
其他人：准备就
Others: Ready to...
其他人： 就是那天晚上
Others: That night.
其他人：准备问他要啊
Others: Ready to ask him for it.
其他人：他说要收我3,000块
Others: He said he would charge me 3,000 yuan.
其他人：想想算了
Others: Think about it, forget it.
其他人：一块混到一起呗
Others: Let's just mix it all together.
Lucia: 武林秘籍才卖你3,000块
Lucia: The martial arts manual only costs you 3,000 yuan.
Lucia: 还嫌贵哈哈
Lucia: And you think it's expensive, haha.
其他人：打折价打折价
Others: Discount price, discount price.
Tasha:你可以在新加坡独步天下了
Tasha: You could dominate Singapore with it.
Lucia: 哈哈
Lucia: Haha.
Alice:你3,000买的秘籍
Alice: You bought the manual for 3,000.
Alice:你300卖出去
Alice: And sold it for 300.
Alice:你卖100 你净赚
Alice: You sell it for 100, you profit.
Lucia: 你可以做成做成电子版
Lucia: You could make an electronic version.
Lucia: 然后就是以300块钱卖电子版
Lucia: And sell the electronic version for 300 yuan.
Lucia: 你可以卖无数个
Lucia: You can sell countless copies.
Lucia: 一本万利啊
Lucia: Huge profit.
Lucia: 哈哈
Lucia: Haha.
Tasha:那个的话
Tasha: That one...
Tasha:用厨房纸巾擦会擦的更干净点
Tasha: It will be cleaner if you wipe it with kitchen paper.
Tasha:在楼上就用这个
Tasha: Upstairs, just use this.
Lucia: 什么厨房纸
Lucia: What kitchen paper?
Lucia: 在楼上吗在楼上
Lucia: Upstairs? Upstairs?
Jake:在楼上吧
Jake: Upstairs, right?
Alice:在楼上在楼上
Alice: Upstairs, upstairs.
Jake:找找去
Jake: Go look for it.
Tasha:就在这呀
Tasha: It's right here.
Jake:二楼煎牛排
Jake: Second floor, grill the steak.
Jake:二楼开火
Jake: Second floor, turn on the stove.
Lucia: 啊这说的是在哪啊
Lucia: Ah, where is this place?
Lucia: 这也没找着啊
Lucia: I can't find it here either.
Lucia: 我感觉这块也没有啊
Lucia: I feel like there's nothing here either.
Jake:没有纸巾
Jake: No napkins?
Lucia: 对
Lucia: Right.
Jake:有的有的有的有的有的
Jake: There are, there are, there are.
Lucia: 哎在哪
Lucia: Oh, where?
Lucia: 不是是那个
Lucia: No, it's that one.
Jake:是这个吗
Jake: Is it this one?
Lucia: 呃不是哎哎
Lucia: Uh, no, wait.
Lucia: 是这个吗
Lucia: Is it this one?
Lucia: 我怎么记得今天微微买了那种
Lucia: I remember Tasha bought that kind today.
Lucia: 就是那种纸巾吸水纸
Lucia: The absorbent napkins.
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh.
Lucia: 您在新加坡见过没
Lucia: Have you seen them in Singapore?
Jake:是卷很很大的那种吗
Jake: The very big rolls?
Lucia: 对就是那种
Lucia: Yeah, those.
Lucia: 你先先问一下他是不是这个吧
Lucia: You should ask him if it's those first.
Jake:好先带一波下去
Jake: Okay, I'll bring some down first.
Lucia: 对我感觉他好像说的是那个
Lucia: Yeah, I feel like he means those.
Lucia: 就是那种吸水纸
Lucia: The absorbent napkins.
Jake:就是先汇报一下
Jake: I'll report it first.
Jake:嗯先有这些东西汇报
Jake: Yeah, report these things first.
Jake:然后再看领导怎么说
Jake: Then see what the leader says.
Jake:哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahahahaha.
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Lucia: 哈哈至少先有点进展是吧
Lucia: At least there's some progress, right?
Lucia: 至于进展怎么样的他
Lucia: As for the progress, he...
Jake:对对对对对
Jake: Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
其他人： 他对你说话的语气好轻
Others: He speaks so gently to you.
Jake:你说话的语气
Jake: Your tone.
Jake:现在有东西了
Jake: Now we have something.
Lucia: 微微你说的是那种
Lucia: Tasha, you mean those...
Tasha:没有没有
Tasha: No, no.
Tasha:我是我是说他居然知道这个
Tasha: I mean, he actually knows this.
Tasha:做甜品是需要无油无水的
Tasha: Making desserts needs to be oil-free and water-free.
Lucia: 哦好厉害啊
Lucia: Oh, impressive.
Jake:好牛逼
Jake: So awesome.
Lucia: 你说的是那种吸水纸吧
Lucia: You're talking about that kind of blotting paper, right?
Lucia: 但是我们只找到了这个
Lucia: But we only found this one.
Tasha:这个吗
Tasha: This one?
Lucia: 在那啊OK
Lucia: Over there, OK.
Jake:好的
Jake: Got it.
Lucia: 我还以为那个在楼上
Lucia: I thought it was upstairs.
Lucia: 我就记得你好像买了一卷这个
Lucia: I remember you bought a roll of this.
Lucia: 那个那个超好用
Lucia: That one is super useful.
Lucia: 特别好用
Lucia: Really useful.
其他人：摔了
Others: Dropped it.
其他人:应该拿下
Others: Should take it down.
其他人: 毫无生活经验的标准
Others: Totally inexperienced.
其他人: 哈哈哈你这把为什么这么短
Others: Haha, why is this one so short?
Tasha:这把为什么这么短
Tasha: Why is this one so short?
其他人:很难很难拿
Others: It's really hard to handle.
Tasha:是的呢要不你去让厂家生产改一下
Tasha: Yeah, maybe you should ask the manufacturer to make some changes.
其他人:厂你买这个
Others: You bought this.
Tasha:好你买的肯定比我好
Tasha: Fine, the one you bought is definitely better than mine.
Tasha:哈哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahaha.
Jake:尬住了尬住了
Jake: It's so awkward.
其他人:一句都说不出来
Others: Can't say a word.
Tasha:要开始了是吗
Tasha: Are we starting?
Tasha:这这就要开始了是吗
Tasha: Are we starting now?
其他人：不然呢
Others: What else?
其他人：要不然他先说你看
Others: Otherwise, he should go first.
其他人：我怕我怕我怕不好
Others: I'm afraid, I'm afraid it won't be good.
其他人：我很会做饭
Others: I'm really good at cooking.
Tasha:你很会做饭好
Tasha: You're really good at cooking, okay.
其他人：哎那个相机开了吗
Others: Hey, is that camera on?
Jake:开了闪了
Jake: It's on, it's flashing.
Jake:就是开了
Jake: It's on.
Jake:他他他我也不懂为什么
Jake: I don't know why, but it's on.
Jake:反正他是开了
Jake: Anyway, it's on.
Jake:每个相机都有自己的个性
Jake: Every camera has its own personality.
其他人: 这不是check一个吗
Others: Isn't this just a check?
Jake:对是
Jake: Yeah, it is.
Jake:我们主要check他
Jake: We're mainly checking it.
Jake:充电宝上面的灯和字是不是亮的
Jake: To see if the lights and the text on the power bank are on.
Jake:关了就这是和面用的
Jake: Turn it off, this is for mixing dough.
Jake:这不行这不行
Jake: This won't work, this won't work.
Tasha:都可以啊怎么用都可以
Tasha: Anything works, however you want to use it.
Lucia: 我去拿件外套
Lucia: I'll go get a jacket.
Lucia: 这样我就可以把它揣口袋里
Lucia: That way I can put it in my pocket.
Jake:嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Lucia: （歌词）难放这里有过
Lucia: (Lyrics) It's hard to let go here.
Lucia: （歌词）凝望你沉睡的轮廓
Lucia: (Lyrics) Gazing at your sleeping silhouette.
Lucia: （歌词）看海天一色听风起
Lucia: (Lyrics) Watching the sea and sky blend, listening to the wind rise.
Lucia: （歌词）茫茫
Lucia: (Lyrics) Vast.
Lucia: （歌词）云朵的翅膀
Lucia: (Lyrics) The wings of the clouds.
Lucia: （歌词） 已经太辽阔
Lucia: (Lyrics) Already too vast.
Tasha:打蛋盆呢
Tasha: Where's the mixing bowl?
Jake:什么盆
Jake: What bowl?
Jake:有他都有
Jake: He has everything.
Jake:那确实
Jake: That's true.
Jake:易烊千玺哎
Jake: Yi Yangqianxi, huh?
Jake:我们好像是什么时候看到的
Jake: When did we see him?
Jake:那个王源
Jake: That Wang Yuan?
Jake:还是哦
Jake: Or oh.
其他人:是那个去去去
Others: That one, go go go.
其他人: 买瑞幸coffee的哦
Others: Buying Luckin Coffee, oh.
其他人:买芙蓉王时能看到王源
Others: Seeing Wang Yuan when buying Furongwang.
其他人:芙蓉王源
Others: Furongwang Yuan.
其他人:尼古丁丁
Others: Nicotine-ting.
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahaha.
其他人:坏了我们顺序要少于顺序
Others: Oh no, we're out of order.
其他人:TF不好意思
Others: TF, sorry.
Jake:哈哈完了完了
Jake: Haha, it's over, it's over.
其他人:我北半球我能收获一大批
Others: I can harvest a bunch in the northern hemisphere.
Tasha:有淡奶油的味道
Tasha: There's a taste of light cream.
Jake:哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahahahaha.
Tasha:没擦干
Tasha: Didn't dry it.
Tasha:这个要保持绝对的干
Tasha: This needs to be completely dry.
其他人:欧欧奥来讲还是赚哈哈哈
Others: Oh, come learn how to beat it, haha.
其他人: 这打蛋器你要不来打
Others: Do you want to beat this egg beater?
Tasha:你要不来打
Tasha: Do you want to beat it?
其他人：来学习一下
Others: Come learn.
其他人：来学打到打到
Others: Come learn to beat it.
Tasha:打到打到这里面
Tasha: Beat it into here.
其他人：打几个
Others: How many to beat?
Jake:他可会打了
Jake: He's really good at it.
其他人：只加蛋清
Tasha:不用你打进去就行了
Jake:他用手可以打蛋黄
Jake:蛋黄弄出来
Jake:可以
其他人：这么高级可以
Lucia: 蛋黄不要了
Tasha:蛋壳不要了
其他人：我来打个蛋先
Tasha:哎等等等等
Tasha:我怕打坏了
Lucia: 要要一个蛋就倒一次
Tasha:哈哈不然的话后果很严重
Lucia: 否则的话就很有浪费的风险很严重
Tasha:OK第二位学徒上场
其他人：就要分开手
Tasha:不用你直接报就行了
其他人：卧槽他非要展示一下
Jake:秀手法这是手法
Jake:这是直接把蛋黄弄破
Lucia: 哇哇
Lucia: Wow, wow.
Alice:你别把蛋黄弄破了
Alice: Don't break the yolk.
其他人:他必须要展示一下
Others: He has to show it off.
Tasha:你把蛋黄弄破了你就死定了
Tasha: If you break the yolk, you're done for.
Jake:活着还活着
Jake: Still alive, still alive.
其他人：我靠牛啊
Others: Wow, that's amazing.
Alice:哈哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha.
Jake:傻逼啊哈哈哈
Jake: What an idiot, hahaha.
Lucia: 膨胀了膨胀了
Lucia: Getting cocky, getting cocky.
Lucia: 哈哈哈受不了了
Lucia: Hahaha, I can't take it.
Jake:你这有变化吗
Jake: Did you see any changes?
Tasha:这蛋黄
Tasha: This yolk...
Tasha:到这哎
Tasha: Right here, hey.
Tasha:干嘛
Tasha: What's up?
Tasha:蛋清蛋清到底
Tasha: The egg white, the egg white all the way.
其他人：这个必须要
Others: This has to...
其他人：这个完整展示一下
Others: This has to be shown completely.
Tasha:嗯好
Tasha: Alright.
Tasha:下一个下一个
Tasha: Next one, next one.
Jake:下一个谁要打下一个
Jake: Who's up next?
Tasha:谁要打不敢打
Tasha: Who wants to hit it but doesn't dare?
Lucia: 下一个我不敢打
Lucia: Next, I don't dare to hit it.
Jake:来来来来来来
Jake: Come on, come on, come on.
其他人:来来来我不敢打
Others: Come on, come on, I don't dare to hit it.
其他人:我只能打打
Others: I can only hit it lightly.
其他人:打进去就不错了
Others: It's good enough if it goes in.
其他人:你别把蛋黄打碎
Others: Don't break the yolk.
其他人:切都没有问题
Others: Cutting is no problem.
Lucia: 哇哦我
Lucia: Wow, I...
Alice:完整
Alice: Complete.
其他人：我发现大家都是高手
Others: I realize everyone here is skilled.
其他人:各显神通
Others: Each shows their talents.
Jake:是
Jake: Yes.
Tasha: OK下一位
Tasha: OK, next one.
Lucia: 哈哈哈哦
Lucia: Hahaha, oh.
其他人：到你了
Others: It's your turn.
其他人：坏了我感觉
Others: Oh no, I feel...
Jake:完完球
Jake: It's over.
Lucia: 哈哈
Lucia: Haha.
Jake:哎可以可以
Jake: Hey, it's okay, it's okay.
其他人：抖叉叉来吧
Others: Jack, come on.
Jake:董莎莎来了董莎莎来
Jake: Jack is here, Jack is here.
其他人：我我有些紧张
Others: I, I'm a bit nervous.
Jake:没关系没关系没关系
Jake: It's alright, it's alright, it's alright.
Lucia: 你来你来
Lucia: You go, you go.
其他人：帮你们贡献一些failure case
Others: I'll contribute some failure cases for you.
Jake:可以可以
Jake: It's okay, it's okay.
Jake:一定成功
Jake: It will definitely succeed.
Alice:有有有在这呢
Alice: Yes, yes, it's here.
Jake:有的有的有的有的
Jake: It's there, it's there, it's there.
Jake:可以成功
Jake: It can succeed.
Alice:给给你玩会
Alice: Here, play with it for a while.
其他人:我只会最基础的
Others: I only know the basics.
Lucia: five goals
Lucia: Five goals.
其他人:因为因为当我需要打鸡蛋的时候
Others: Because, because when I need to crack eggs...
Alice:呃要接一个
Alice: Uh, need to catch one.
其他人:只会用来炒鸡蛋
Others: I only use it to make scrambled eggs.
Alice:那个转子啊在这
Alice: The rotor, it's here.
其他人：不会用来干别的
Others: Don't use it for anything else.
其他人:哦这是这个是吧
Others: Oh, this is it, right?
Alice:对对对
Alice: Yes, yes, yes.
其他人：哎呦
Others: Oh my!
Tasha:你应该知道
Tasha: You should know.
Lucia: 那必须已经非常熟练了
Lucia: You must be really skilled by now.
其他人:他干嘛去
Others: Where is he going?
其他人:我好高级
Others: I feel so advanced.
其他人:感觉非常厉害
Others: It feels amazing.
其他人:卧槽我要学一下打五个单
Others: Wow, I need to learn how to hit five singles.
其他人:五个蛋试一下
Others: Try hitting five eggs.
Tasha:最高5分钟都打到
Tasha: The maximum is 5 minutes to hit.
Tasha:不能再打了
Tasha: Can't hit anymore.
其他人:我在我家
Others: I'm at home.
其他人:我自己打篮球怎么打都打不起来
Others: No matter how I play basketball at home, I can't score.
其他人:你自己还打嗯
Others: You still play by yourself, huh?
其他人:加加加多少
Others: How much to add?
其他人:这个怎么锁
Others: How do you lock this?
其他人:你把你的配料贡献出来
Others: Share your ingredients.
其他人:就他有在这吗
Others: Is he here?
Lucia: 他有一个花你那按进去
Lucia: He has a flower, press it in.
Lucia: 对顺着他就就按一下就可以了
Lucia: Yes, just press it in, and it'll be set.
其他人：然后呢
Others: And then?
Alice:按比例就这样按进去
Alice: Press it proportionally.
Lucia: 哦不用就这样
Lucia: Oh, no need, just like this.
Lucia: 对按进去只要他不掉就他就按上了
Lucia: Yes, press it in, as long as it doesn't fall, it's set.
Lucia: 对就已经好了
Lucia: Yes, it's done.
Tasha:大家都看着我
Tasha: Everyone is watching me.
Tasha:我有点紧张了
Tasha: I'm a bit nervous.
Jake:这是一代宗师和门下弟子
Jake: This is a grandmaster and his disciples.
Lucia: 哈哈哈我想要矿泉水清水
Lucia: Hahaha, I want mineral water, clear water.
Jake:哈哈哈我想要矿泉水
Jake: Hahaha, I want mineral water.
Tasha:我想要矿泉水
Tasha: I want mineral water.
Tasha:清水水
Tasha: Clear water.
Jake:师傅想喝水
Jake: The master wants water.
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Tasha:不是我想喝水这药水
Tasha: No, I want water, this potion.
Jake:矿泉水
Jake: Mineral water.
Lucia: 我们有
Lucia: We have it.
Lucia: 这个也行吧
Lucia: This should work, right?
Lucia: 这是纯净水吗
Lucia: Is this purified water?
Lucia: 啊那行
Lucia: Ah, that'll do.
Lucia: 我记得刚刚应该有几个杯子
Lucia: I remember there were a few cups just now.
Lucia: 是我洗过的
Lucia: I washed them.
Lucia: 是这个吗
Lucia: Is it this one?
Lucia: 管他呢冲一下哈哈
Lucia: Whatever, just rinse it, haha.
Tasha:哎干什么
Tasha: Hey, what are you doing?
Jake:比划比划
Jake: Just gesturing.
Jake:电脑没插
Jake: The computer isn't plugged in.
Tasha:等会给你用
Tasha: I'll let you use it later.
Jake:好
Jake: Okay.
其他人:那个打蛋的呢
Others: Where's the egg beater?
其他人:那个去哪里了
Others: Where did it go?
其他人:有关系吗
Others: Does it matter?
Jake:喝掉喝掉
Jake: Just drink it up.
Lucia: 够吗
Lucia: Is this enough?
其他人:你不去皮吗
Others: Aren't you going to peel it?
其他人:清水加50110
Others: Add 50110 of water.
其他人:然后100
Others: Then 100.
其他人:多多奖励
Others: More rewards.
Alice:无妨
Alice: No worries.
Tasha:您来搅
Tasha: You stir.
其他人：用这个搅
Others: Use this to stir.
Lucia: 不用哈哈哈
Lucia: No need, haha.
Tasha:不用
Tasha: No need.
Tasha:不要哈哈
Tasha: Don't, haha.
Lucia: 那个这么小的碗会打飞出去吗
Lucia: Will this small bowl fly out?
Jake:对
Jake: Yes.
其他人:搅到什么程度
Others: To what extent should it be stirred?
Tasha:找到他们俩完全融合
Tasha: Until they are completely mixed.
Lucia: 算了我拿着吧
Lucia: Forget it, I'll hold it.
Lucia: 好没地放
Lucia: Okay, no place to put it.
其他人:水和油还能融合吗
Others: Can water and oil even mix?
Jake:就是可以融合
Jake: They can mix.
Jake:师傅说可以融合
Jake: The master said they can mix.
其他人:好
Others: Okay.
Jake:哈哈哈不没法牛顿算什么
Jake: Haha, no, Newton doesn't count for anything.
Alice:哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahahahahaha.
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈听师傅的
Lucia: Hahaha, listen to the master.
Tasha:哈
Tasha: Haha.
Shure: 好给明给牛顿刨了给师傅
Shure: Okay, let's give Newton to the master tomorrow.
Tasha:哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahahahahaha
其他人:你是不是埋进去
Others: Are you buried in there?
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈高级高级
Lucia: Hahahahahaha, so advanced, so advanced!
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha
Jake:哈哈哈哈哈可以可以可以如何
Jake: Hahahaha, okay, okay, how is it?
其他人：高级高级
Others: So advanced, so advanced!
Tasha:找到完全融合
Tasha: Completely blended
其他人:你觉得如何
Others: What do you think?
Tasha:我觉得没有
Tasha: I don't think so.
Shure: 咱俩这辈子也不可能如何
Shure: There's no way we can do this in our lifetime.
Jake:哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahahaha
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahahahaha
Alice:哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha
Jake:还能变成金子
Jake: It can turn into gold.
Shure: 我从小接受的知识不允许我干这种事
Shure: The knowledge I was taught since childhood doesn't allow me to do this.
其他人：油水混合物
Others: Oil-water mixture
Lucia: 油水混合物
Lucia: Oil-water mixture
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha
其他人:但是变成特别小
Others: But it becomes very small.
其他人:的那种对
Others: Yes, small pieces.
其他人：对一个个小的块
其他人:这个时候你给他加一点那个洗衣剂
Others: At this point, you add a bit of detergent.
其他人:也就是乳化
Others: That's emulsification.
Lucia: 哈哈别把还能吃吗
Lucia: Haha, can you still eat it?
其他人:哈哈哈
Others: Hahaha
Tasha:再搅一搅
Tasha: Stir it some more.
Tasha:我帮你倒下一个东西
Tasha: I'll help you pour the next thing.
其他人:怎么感觉搅成面糊的感觉
Others: Why does it feel like it's turning into dough?
其他人:那个大的都去哪了
Others: Where did the big pieces go?
Lucia: 什么这个吗
Lucia: This one?
Lucia: 在这啊哦
Lucia: Here it is, oh.
Jake:装蛋清哦
Jake: Put the egg whites in.
Lucia: 那个在冰箱里
Lucia: It's in the fridge.
Tasha: 完了完了完了
Tasha: It's over, it's over, it's over.
其他人:还要冰一会是吧
Others: Do we need to chill it for a while?
Lucia: 对对对
Lucia: Yes, yes, yes.
Lucia: 他是我们接下来会用到的妙妙小工具
Lucia: It's the magical little tool we'll use next.
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahahahahaha
Jake:哈哈哈妙妙妙妙小冰壶
Jake: Hahaha, magical little ice pot.
其他人:你先去皮
Others: You start peeling first.
Tasha:去了放放
Tasha: I went to put it down.
其他人:你这你这
Others: Look at you, look at you.
Tasha:没关系我知道了
Tasha: It's okay, I got it.
其他人:40.8叫加50
Others: 40.8, let's call it 50.
其他人:多一点多一点
Others: A bit more, a bit more.
其他人:卧槽精益求精
Others: Whoa, striving for perfection.
其他人:没事多一点多一点多一点
Others: It's okay, a bit more, a bit more, a bit more.
其他人:多吃一口
Others: Eat a bit more.
Jake:多吃1/500
Jake: Eat 1/500 more.
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Tasha:继续搅
Tasha: Keep stirring.
其他人:我靠可以拿那个打蛋器吗
Others: Whoa, can we use that whisk?
Jake:哈哈喜欢打碗的
Jake: Haha, loves to break bowls.
Alice:不可以
Alice: No, you can't.
其他人:这个可以
Others: This one works.
Tasha:那个太大了
Tasha: That one is too big.
其他人:这正经面糊这味
Others: This batter smells legit.
Alice:算盘我来吧不是
Alice: Let me do the calculations, no wait.
其他人:纸杯蛋糕
Others: Cupcakes.
Tasha:不是的
Tasha: No, it's not.
Lucia: 纸杯蛋糕的纸杯
Lucia: Cupcake liners.
其他人:哦这肉松小
Others: Oh, this shredded pork is small.
其他人：这是什么东西
Others: What is this stuff?
Lucia: 玉米淀粉
Lucia: Cornstarch.
其他人:搅了
Others: Stirred.
Jake:不带劲啊
Jake: Not exciting enough.
其他人:来看着很有食欲
Others: It looks appetizing.
其他人:我来
Others: I'll do it.
Jake:强度你这几档的
Jake: What's the strength, which gear are you using?
Jake:2档的这5档的
Jake: Second gear, this is fifth gear.
其他人：要涨到多少
Others: How high should it rise?
Jake:这个要涨到多少
Jake: How high should this rise?
其他人:还要加
Others: Still needs more.
其他人:哎呦我操
Others: Oh my god.
Tasha:倒到这个里面来吧
Tasha: Pour it into this one.
Jake:哦现在你可以用你的机器了哦
Jake: Oh, now you can use your machine.
Tasha:可以用那个蛋抽了
Tasha: You can use that whisk.
Tasha:呃那个那个蛋抽不是机器
Tasha: Uh, that whisk is not a machine.
Jake:机器插链了哦
Jake: The machine is plugged in now.
Jake:蛋抽哦
Jake: Whisk.
Jake:还没到机器对
Jake: It's not time for the machine yet.
其他人:这个碗底不要了吗
Others: Do we not need this bowl anymore?
Tasha: 不用了好
Tasha: No, it's fine.
其他人:所以说你刚刚进一球就没系列了
Others: So, you scored a goal and that was it?
其他人:是为了让他配比是不是
Others: Was it to get the right mix?
Alice:配比是对的
Alice: The mix is correct.
其他人:那个得洗一下
Others: This needs to be washed.
Tasha:洗了之后用那个厨房纸巾擦一擦
Tasha: After washing, wipe it with a kitchen paper towel.
Tasha:要干燥哦
Tasha: It needs to be dry.
Jake:他没开光肿
Jake: He didn't turn it on.
Lucia: 其他人：
Lucia: Others:
其他人:配料什么的
Others: What about the ingredients?
Tasha:什么配料
Tasha: What ingredients?
其他人：是糖什么糖
Others: The sugar, what kind of sugar?
其他人:不是还有15克的糖
Others: Isn't there still 15 grams of sugar?
其他人:忘了
Others: Forgot about it.
Tasha: 那就现在加吧
Tasha: Then add it now.
Jake:好的哈哈哈
Jake: Alright, haha.
其他人:失误失误
Others: My mistake, my mistake.
Jake:没有菜单不对
Jake: The recipe is incorrect.
其他人:OK可以少加点糖
Others: Okay, just add less sugar.
Jake:对应该菜单回去修改一下
Jake: Yeah, we should revise the recipe.
其他人:应该什么时候加糖
Others: When should the sugar be added?
Jake:就现在就现在就现在就现在
Jake: Right now, right now, right now.
Tasha: 就现在
Tasha: Right now.
Jake:这没差别吧
Jake: There's no difference, right?
Jake:这应该没差别
Jake: There should be no difference.
其他人:不太懂他
Others: I don't quite understand him.
Jake:还没有发生什么化学变化
Jake: No chemical reaction has occurred yet.
其他人:师傅你怎么了
Others: Master, what's wrong?
其他人：这说的是什么
Others: What is he talking about?
其他人：肉松小杯
Others: Floss cake?
Jake:对
Jake: Yes.
其他人:其实底料都是一样的
Others: Actually, the base ingredients are all the same.
Lucia: 他真的好了解哈哈哈
Lucia: He really knows his stuff, haha.
其他人:你调的那个面包坯子都是一样
Others: The dough you prepared is all the same.
Lucia: 麦当劳麦当劳
Lucia: McDonald's, McDonald's.
Jake:麦当劳麦当劳汉堡
Jake: McDonald's, McDonald's burger.
Jake:啊现在是啊
Jake: Ah, it is now.
Tasha: 蛋清
Tasha: Egg whites.
Lucia: 啊现在拿下来是吧
Lucia: Ah, now take it off, right?
Lucia: 对嗯我看我看
Lucia: Yes, let me see, let me see.
其他人:哪有你这样打的
Others: How can you hit it like that?
Jake:哈哈哈我觉得他这
Jake: Hahaha, I think his way...
Lucia: 我觉得他这
Lucia: I think his way...
Lucia: 他这个已经达到那个打蛋器的五档了
Lucia: He's already reached level five on the mixer.
其他人:菠萝肉松小杯前面加点茉莉花茶
Others: A small pineapple meat floss cup with some jasmine tea.
其他人:或者这个葡萄
Others: Or these grapes.
Jake:师傅喜欢吃瓜子
Jake: Master likes eating sunflower seeds.
Jake:哈哈哈不是瓜
Jake: Hahaha, not the melon.
Jake:瓜子仁我觉得烤一烤可以
Jake: Sunflower seeds, I think roasting them is good.
Tasha: 来来来你来打这个吧
Tasha: Come on, come hit this.
Tasha: 好了好了
Tasha: Alright, alright.
Jake:这面糊里面放点花生仁吧
Jake: Let's put some peanuts in the batter.
Jake:是吧合理吧
Jake: Right? Makes sense, right?
Lucia: 我得再来个杯子
Lucia: I need another cup.
Lucia: 哎又没了
Lucia: Oh, it's gone again.
Lucia: 我刚洗那些上哪去了
Lucia: Where did the ones I just washed go?
Tasha: 不不我还以为你真会
Tasha: No, no, I thought you really knew how.
Jake:麦当劳汉堡
Jake: McDonald's burger.
Jake:哎搜不到麦当劳
Jake: Hey, can't find McDonald's.
Jake:为啥
Jake: Why?
其他人:你去那个麦当劳小程序里看一看
Others: Try checking the McDonald's mini program.
其他人:美团呢
Others: Or Meituan?
Jake:谁有麦当劳小程序
Jake: Who has the McDonald's mini program?
Jake:你有吗
Jake: Do you have it?
Jake:来来来试试
Jake: Come on, come on, try it.
Jake:试试
Jake: Try it.
Jake:因为没有
Jake: Because there's none.
Jake:美团上没有
Jake: Not on Meituan.
Lucia: 你
Lucia: You...
Lucia: （歌词）在安静的往昔里游荡
Lucia: (Lyrics) Wandering in the quiet past.
Lucia: （歌词）   如果你是生
Lucia: (Lyrics) If you are born...
其他人：就奶油其实这是奶油吗
Others: Is this really cream?
Tasha:打到现在
Tasha: Beaten till now.
Tasha:打到他提起来不会掉下来
Tasha: Beat it until it doesn't fall when lifted.
Tasha:呃提起来有小弯钩就行
Tasha: Uh, it's fine if it forms a small hook when lifted.
Tasha:你没有呢
Tasha: You don't have it.
Tasha:远远没有
Tasha: Nowhere near it.
Jake:哎呦只能只能到店取餐呢
Jake: Oh, you can only pick up the order at the store.
Jake:啥意思啊
Jake: What do you mean?
Tasha:那就找个跑腿喽
Tasha: Then just find a delivery person.
其他人：到店取
Others: Pick up at the store.
Jake:找个跑腿嗯
Jake: Find a delivery person, hmm.
Lucia: 是你
Lucia: It's you.
Jake:师傅说要把它给提起来
Jake: The master said to lift it up.
Jake:不行然后不行
Jake: No, then no.
Jake:对
Jake: Right.
Jake:香的哈哈哈
Jake: Smells good, hahaha.
Tasha: 奶盖不是这么做的
Tasha: This is not how you make milk cap.
其他人：奶盖加奶油
Others: Milk cap with cream.
其他人:奶油是什么做的
Others: What is cream made of?
Tasha: 奶油奶油
Tasha: Cream, cream.
Tasha: 不是猪奶油
Tasha: Not pig cream.
Tasha: 在冰箱里
Tasha: It's in the fridge.
Jake:怎么点宝宝随心拼
Jake: How to order the Baby's Choice?
Jake:我来看看现在麦当劳都有点啥
Jake: Let me see what McDonald's has now.
Jake:铂金奶铁我靠
Jake: Platinum milk iron, wow.
Tasha: 等一下
Tasha: Wait a minute.
Tasha: 再加最后一个定型的东西就行
Tasha: Just add one last setting agent and it's done.
Jake:麦当劳
Jake: McDonald's.
Jake:麦当劳还卖小酥肉啊
Jake: McDonald's sells crispy pork too?
其他人:啊麦当劳这么好吃
Others: Wow, McDonald's is so tasty.
Lucia: 麦当劳这么着急
Lucia: McDonald's is in such a hurry.
Jake:我靠是颠覆认知啊
Jake: Wow, this is mind-blowing.
Jake:然后放肉松啊
Jake: Then add the shredded pork.
Jake:这什么东西啊
Jake: What is this?
其他人：喝了啥小苏打呃
Others: What did you drink, baking soda?
Jake:差不多大苏打呵呵
Jake: Almost like baking soda, haha.
其他人:已经厌倦
Others: Already tired of it.
其他人：这是什么
Others: What is this?
Tasha:好再充分搅拌一下就OK了
Tasha: Okay, just mix it thoroughly and it's done.
Tasha:打发到不能再变大
Tasha: Whip it until it can't get bigger.
Tasha:一直打一直打
Tasha: Keep whipping, keep whipping.
Tasha:打到他不会再变大
Tasha: Whip it until it can't get bigger.
其他人:他已经变大了
Others: It's already bigger.
Tasha:你他有没有变大嘛
Tasha: Did it get bigger or not?
其他人：没感觉
Others: Can't tell.
Tasha:你说蛋清
Tasha: You mean the egg whites.
其他人：我感觉这个有点就是
Others: I feel like this is kind of...
Alice:这两个加起来
Alice: Add these two together.
Jake:那他他准备
Jake: Then he's getting ready.
Alice:打开了
Alice: It's open.
Jake:师傅准备找个跑腿
Jake: The master is getting ready to find a runner.
其他人:离多远我们过去
Others: How far away are we going?
Jake:2.4公里
Jake: 2.4 kilometers.
Jake:也不是不行
Jake: It's doable.
Tasha:打发到你觉得不能再变大的位置
Tasha: Send it to the point where you think it can't get any bigger.
Tasha:就OK了
Tasha: Then it's okay.
其他人:随你蛋黄和蛋白分开加的剂
Others: You can add the egg yolk and egg white separately.
Tasha: 嗯
Tasha: Hmm.
Tasha: 分开加的意义
Tasha: What's the point of adding them separately?
其他人:你的蛋白掺着蛋黄没办法给他打营养
Others: If you mix the egg white with the yolk, you can't whip it properly.
其他人:但你可以一块打
Others: But you can whip them together.
其他人:不行不可以一块打
Others: No, you can't whip them together.
其他人:就是只有蛋白和蛋白打鸡蛋的做法
Others: You should only whip the egg whites separately for certain recipes.
其他人：接人呢够了
Others: Picking someone up is enough.
Jake:勾人呢啊勾了
Jake: Hooking someone up, huh?
Jake:来师傅坐
Jake: Come on, master, have a seat.
Tasha: 不对
Tasha: No, that's not right.
Jake:师傅坐师傅坐
Jake: Please have a seat, master.
Tasha: 不对劲
Tasha: Something's off.
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahahahahaha.
Jake:我看你不对劲
Jake: You seem off.
Jake:看你不对劲
其他人:太稀了是吗
Others: Is it too thin?
其他人:对确实太稀了
Others: Yeah, it's too thin.
其他人:为什么这么稀
Others: Why is it so thin?
其他人:你水加多了
Others: You added too much water.
Tasha: 没有不对
Tasha: No, that's not right.
Jake:那怎么办呢
Jake: So what do we do?
其他人:主要是你打的手法不对
Others: It's mainly your technique.
Tasha: 继续打吧
Tasha: Just keep going.
其他人:到了
Others: Here it comes.
Jake:啥意思啊
Jake: What do you mean?
Jake:打反了哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: You stirred it the wrong way, hahaha.
其他人： 那么稀呀
Others: It's so thin.
Jake:那还能怎么回事啊
Jake: What else could it be?
Jake:师傅为啥呀
Jake: Master, why?
Lucia: 多打一会吧
Lucia: Let's play a bit longer.
其他人:你是不是淀粉多少
Others: Are you a starch fan?
Jake:你知道Revere吗
Jake: Do you know Revere?
Jake:就是说不对你就不行
Jake: It means if it's not right, you can't handle it.
Tasha:算了稀了加粉
Tasha: Forget it, add some starch.
Tasha:粉了加干了加加水
Tasha: Add starch if it's too thin, add water if it's too thick.
其他人:但是Revere就没有这么好哦
Others: But Revere isn't that good.
其他人：有没有人会告诉你
Others: Did anyone tell you?
其他人：你适合就投下一个
Others: If it suits you, vote for the next one.
其他人：不适合这个就投下一个
Others: If it doesn't suit you, vote for the next one.
Jake:这我真会写
Jake: I can really write this.
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Jake:我觉得你这个更适合
Jake: I think this suits you better.
Jake:哈哈哈AC芭提比
Jake: Hahaha, AC Bartybi.
Jake:这样哈哈哈
Jake: Like this, hahaha.
其他人：砍一下速
Others: Slow down a bit.
Jake:他干嘛呢
Jake: What's he doing?
Jake:他干活呢
Jake: He's working.
Jake:好嘞我草你
Jake: Alright, I'll do it.
其他人:我操逆天了
Others: Oh my god, it's amazing.
其他人:我真扯到波塔了
Others: I'm really impressed with Bota.
其他人：开起慢
Others: Start it slowly.
Jake:你们公共区域在哪啊
Jake: Where is your common area?
其他人:公共区域应该在台湾区那个什么Patro
Others: The common area should be in the Taiwan area, something Patro.
Jake:那你
Jake: Then you...
Jake:那你弄过来呗
Jake: Then bring it over.
其他人:我已经忘了康大该怎么软硬我怎么来
Others: I've already forgotten how to use the Kangda soft and hard.
Lucia: 为什么会好像没什么
Lucia: Why does it seem like there's no...
Lucia: 变化呀他应该会怎么样
Lucia: Change? How should it be?
其他人：应该会特别稠是吗
Others: It should be really thick, right?
Lucia: 理论上会越打越稠好像
Lucia: Theoretically, it should get thicker and thicker.
Jake:你点了吗
Jake: Did you press it?
Jake:没点好嘞
Jake: Didn't press it, okay.
Tasha:没关系我看他们用除湿机要打5分钟
Tasha: It's okay, I saw them use a dehumidifier, it takes 5 minutes.
Tasha:这种手抽机的话可能要打个10分钟吧
Tasha: For this kind of manual machine, it might take about 10 minutes.
Jake:你坐着打吧
Jake: You can sit and do it.
Jake:要不抱着打吧
Jake: Or hold it and do it.
Lucia: 请
Lucia: Please.
Jake:好 10分钟之后见
Jake: Okay, see you in 10 minutes.
Jake:哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahahaha.
Lucia: 哈哈 7分钟最后见
Lucia: Haha, see you in 7 minutes.
Lucia: 休息一下马上回来
Lucia: Let's take a quick break and be right back.
Lucia: 好我们可以咔了哈哈
Lucia: Okay, we can cut now, haha.
Tasha:这个状态是很不对的
Tasha: This doesn't feel right.
Alice:妈的香薰
Alice: Damn, the aroma.
Tasha:如果实在不行
Tasha: If it really doesn't work...
Lucia: 啊这是你说要放桌子上那个香薰
Lucia: Oh, this is the aroma you said you wanted on the table.
Tasha:那就加面粉吧
Tasha: Then just add some flour.
Alice:对
Alice: Yes.
其他人:你可以再加点啊
Others: You can add a bit more.
Alice:好我现在要开始去装修我的地方了
Alice: Okay, I'm going to start redecorating my place now.
其他人:再稍微加一点
Others: Add just a little more.
Tasha:再看一看吧
Tasha: Let's take another look.
其他人:水或者什么加太多
Others: Too much water or something.
其他人:什么都没加多呀
Others: We didn't add too much of anything.
Alice:你也要来吗
Alice: Are you coming too?
其他人:不是每个都各各多了一克
Others: Not every bit was one gram too much.
Lucia: 可以看一眼吗
Lucia: Can I take a look?
Alice:可以
Alice: Sure.
其他人:你看现在是不是稍微熟
Others: Does it look a little cooked now?
Lucia: 我一会也去检查一下
Lucia: I'll check it out later too.
Lucia: 我的快递到了啊
Lucia: My package has arrived.
Lucia: 你这个好好看啊很森系
Alice:我刚弄的啊
Alice: I just made it.
Alice:我需要把这个给洗一下
Alice: I need to wash this.
Alice:哎呦我的天呐
Alice: Oh my god.
Alice:好沉呀这个
Alice: This is so heavy.
Alice:呀呀呀
Alice: Ah, ah, ah.
Lucia: 我看看快递到了多少
Lucia: Let me see how many packages have arrived.
Lucia: 床裙
Lucia: Bed skirt.
Lucia: 今天应该只有一个京东是我的了
Lucia: Today, there should only be one from JD that's mine.
Lucia: 剩下的看看淘宝
Lucia: The rest, let's check Taobao.
Jake:买几个弹弓过来玩
Jake: Buy a few slingshots to play with.
Lucia: 弹弓过来
Lucia: Slingshots?
Jake:因为很多是石子
Jake: Because there are a lot of pebbles.
Lucia: 哦
Lucia: Oh.
Jake:砸玻璃哈哈哈哈
Jake: Smash some windows, haha.
Jake:看看哪位邻居的玻璃比较脆
Jake: See which neighbor's windows are the weakest.
Lucia: 他们不会没取我的吧
Lucia: They didn't take my package, did they?
Jake:啊那你你的号再给他们说一下吧
Jake: Ah, then give them your number again.
Lucia: 我没有看到有我的呀
Lucia: I didn't see mine.
Lucia: 嗯我写的名字是猪先生
Lucia: Hmm, the name I wrote is Mr. Pig.
Jake:写的名字
Jake: The name you wrote
Jake:是你的名字吗
Jake: Is it your name?
Lucia: 对我觉得他好像
Lucia: Yeah, I think he
Lucia: 我觉得他没有
Lucia: I think he didn't
Lucia: 不会忘了吧
Lucia: He wouldn't forget, right?
Lucia: 靠让我再进去看一眼
Lucia: Gosh, let me go back in and check again.
Lucia: 不会吧不会吧不会吧
Lucia: No way, no way, no way.
Alice:不会吧不会吧不会吧
Alice: No way, no way, no way.
Lucia: sorry
Lucia: Sorry.
Lucia: 哎真的
Lucia: Ah, really.
Lucia: 真的我觉得他
Lucia: Really, I think he
Alice:哎呦我的狗
Alice: Oh my dog.
Lucia: 让我看看
Lucia: Let me take a look.
其他人：外面好凉快
Others: It's so cool outside.
Lucia: 对我问一下群里什么情况
Lucia: Right, let me ask in the group what's going on.
Jake:还有人没点吗
Jake: Is there anyone who hasn't checked in?
Jake:哈哈你是谁
Jake: Haha, who are you?
Jake:哈哈哈我是谁哈哈
Jake: Hahaha, who am I, haha.
Lucia: 啊这样的吗
Lucia: Ah, is that so?
Lucia: 但是我给他发了截图
Lucia: But I sent him a screenshot.
Lucia: 就是那个取件码
Lucia: It was the pickup code.
其他人:鸡蛋坏了是不是
Others: Are the eggs spoiled?
其他人:鸡蛋不对
Others: The eggs aren't right.
其他人：我靠这不这晚上在这debug
Others: Damn, debugging this at night.
其他人:味是对的
Others: The taste is right.
其他人：非常的舒适有没有
Others: It's very comfortable, isn't it?
其他人：可能不抵8个球就是了
Others: Maybe it's not worth 8 balls though.
其他人：我要反思了
Others: I need to reflect.
Jake:啊
Jake: Ah.
Jake:哈哈哈反思
Jake: Hahaha, reflect.
Lucia: 我感觉好像没有
Lucia: I feel like there's none.
其他人:我要反思
Others: I need to reflect.
其他人:我是爱反思的中国人
Others: I'm a reflective Chinese. 社会问题
Jake:挺好
Jake: Not bad.
Lucia: 对这收件人不是我的名字
Jake:群里问问吧
Jake: Ask in the group.
Lucia: 我发了一个不知道他们看到没
Lucia: I sent one, don't know if they saw it.
Jake:发了哈
Jake: Sent it, huh.
其他人:好嘞安慕希菠萝酸奶麦旋风
Others: Alright, Anmuxi pineapple yogurt McFlurry.
其他人:我靠这个看着就想吃
Others: Whoa, this looks so good, I want to eat it.
Jake:买一赠一了
Jake: Buy one get one free.
Jake:甜点不能太多
Jake: Don't have too many desserts.
Jake:就这个看着给外国人震慑一下
Jake: Just this one, to impress the foreigners.
其他人：第二份半价呗
Others: The second one is half price.
Jake:已经搬家了呀
Jake: It's already moved.
Jake:对我我已经点了两个了
Jake: Yeah, I already ordered two.
Jake:我已经点了第二份半价了
Jake: I already got the second one for half price.
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh.
Tasha:这个的托呢
Tasha: Where's the tray for this?
Jake:托
Jake: Tray.
Tasha:好了你不知道在哪
Tasha: Okay, you don't know where it is?
其他人：我闻到一股加热的味道好香哦
Others: I smell something heating up, it smells so good.
Jake:烤箱预热预热中
Jake: The oven is preheating.
Alice:你点了吗
Alice: Did you order?
其他人:你鼻子非常的敏感
Others: Your nose is really sensitive.
Lucia: 没呢
Lucia: Not yet.
Jake:这是鼻子干的事吧哈哈哈
Jake: That's because of the nose, haha.
Lucia: 哎我们现在吃的
Lucia: Hey, what are we eating now?
Lucia: 是奥麦当劳啊
Lucia: It's McDonald's, right?
Tasha:没事没事没事找个托我们开始加热吧
Tasha: It's okay, it's okay, let's find a tray and start heating it up.
Jake:托找不到找不着
Jake: Can't find the tray.
Jake:托是在这里头吗
Jake: Is the tray in here?
Tasha: 那怎么办呢
Tasha: Then what should we do?
Jake:是在这里头
Jake: It's in here.
Jake:哎呦我靠
Jake: Oh my gosh.
Tasha:是在这里头吗
Tasha: Is it in here?
Jake:试试
Jake: Try it.
Tasha:搁哪呢
Tasha: Where is it?
Jake:不知道啊
Jake: I don't know.
Tasha:你翻一翻呀
Tasha: Flip it over.
Tasha:扒拉扒拉呀
Tasha: Rummage through it.
Tasha:哇靠哈哈
Tasha: Whoa, haha.
Jake:哈哈哈还还好还好皮厚
Jake: Haha, it's okay, it's okay, thick skin.
Jake:我靠哈哈
Jake: Oh my gosh, haha.
Jake:我靠师傅直接一刀
Jake: Oh my gosh, the master cut it straight through.
Jake:哈哈哈师傅刀我靠
Jake: Haha, the master's knife, oh my gosh.
Jake:砍一刀
Jake: Cut it with one chop.
Tasha: 怎么办没有
Tasha: What do we do, we don't have it.
Jake:砍一刀还好还好皮厚
Jake: Cut it once, it's fine, the skin is thick.
Tasha:没有
Tasha: We don't have it.
Tasha:没有怎么办
Tasha: What do we do if we don't have it?
其他人:刀太炖了好烫
Others: The knife is too blunt, it's too hot.
Jake:哈哈哈没有直接倒进去
Jake: Hahaha, if we don't have it, just pour it in.
其他人:没有直接倒进去
Others: If we don't have it, just pour it in.
Tasha:不行
Tasha: No way.
其他人:拿手固定呗
Others: Just hold it with your hand.
Tasha:那你手也放在烤箱里了
Tasha: Then your hand will be in the oven too.
其他人：是这个味吗不是
Others: Is this the right flavor? No, it isn't.
其他人：为什么鸡蛋给打打打开了就这么香呢
Others: Why does it smell so good when the egg is cracked open?
Tasha:这不是鸡蛋的问题吧
Tasha: It's not because of the egg, right?
Jake:找到了这算没有
Jake: Found it, does this count as not having it?
其他人:那是哪个香面粉蛋糕粉香
Others: Then which one smells good? The cake flour or the regular flour?
Tasha:没有
Tasha: We don't have it.
其他人:蛋糕粉也不香糖香
Others: The cake flour doesn't smell good either, it's the sugar that smells good.
Tasha: 糖和鸡蛋
Tasha: Sugar and eggs.
其他人:谁研究的谁研究的这玩意
Others: Who researched this stuff?
Tasha:从高处没过筛呢
Tasha: It wasn't sifted from a height.
Tasha:搞什么呢
Tasha: What are you doing?
Tasha:筛网
Tasha: The sieve.
Alice:嗯这个有这个的
Alice: Hmm, this one has it.
Alice:这个有这个可乐给你吧哦行了
Alice: This one has it, here, have a Coke. Oh, okay.
Lucia: 啊行啊
Lucia: Ah, alright.
Jake:哈哈一个批房啊
Jake: Hahaha, it's a critique room.
Jake:啊这是一个批房啊
Jake: Ah, this is a critique room.
Alice:我看我买的啥
Alice: Let me see what I bought.
Jake:进来的人一定是批人
Jake: The person who comes in must be a critic.
Alice:厚牛堡
Alice: Thick beef burger.
Alice:好了
Alice: Alright.
Jake:点完了都点完了
Jake: Finished ordering, all done.
Jake:都点了
Jake: All ordered.
Lucia: 我还没点
Lucia: I haven't ordered yet.
Jake:哦好
Jake: Oh, okay.
Jake:你选哪一個
Jake: Which one do you want?
Jake:加一看你选哪一个加1
Jake: Add one, let's see which one you choose, add one.
Jake:所以还是没找着是吧
Jake: So, still can't find it, right?
Jake:不行
Jake: No.
Jake:哼这包还在这
Jake: Hmph, this bag is still here.
Jake:包还没变过呢
Jake: The bag hasn't changed yet.
Jake:开始魔法
Jake: Let's start the magic.
其他人：看看现在上面是谁呀
Others: Look who's on it now.
Jake:你猜是谁
Jake: Guess who it is.
Tasha: 好了继续
Tasha: Alright, let's continue.
Jake:不是
Jake: No.
Jake:no哈哈哈
Jake: No, hahaha.
其他人:咱们往里面加点那个
Others: Let's add some of that.
Tasha:你这么爱吃菠萝吗
Tasha: Do you really love eating pineapple that much?
其他人:就是随便加点
Others: Just add a bit of it.
其他人:加点菠萝然后草莓
Others: Add some pineapple and then strawberries.
Jake:主要是看到的菠萝
Jake: Mainly because I saw the pineapple.
Jake:他说看到草莓应该也会加
Jake: He said if he sees strawberries, he'll add them too.
Jake:你不得切一切
Jake: You gotta cut it up.
Jake:哎好嘞
Jake: Alright, got it.
其他人:但是我不知道他家烤菜是不是我一样
Others: But I don't know if his roasted dish is the same as mine.
其他人:用的烤菠萝
Others: Using roasted pineapple.
其他人:是是是
Others: Yes, yes, yes.
Jake:火烤啊
Jake: Roasted with fire.
其他人：你这个小菠萝
Others: You're such a little pineapple.
Tasha: 这在哪拍啊
Tasha: Where was this shot?
Tasha:拿12个
Tasha: Grab 12 of them.
Jake:哦这边有镊子
Jake: Oh, there's tweezers here.
Tasha:把托找一下行吗
Tasha: Can you find the tray?
Jake:把什么托
Jake: Which tray?
Tasha:托
Tasha: The tray.
Jake:对我在找托
Jake: Yeah, I'm looking for the tray.
其他人:那我就不客气了
Others: Then I won't be polite.
其他人：你需要做啥
Others: What do you need to make?
其他人：蛋挞
Others: Egg tarts.
Tasha:这个蛋挞很简单
Tasha: These egg tarts are very easy.
Tasha:来个简单的
Tasha: Let's make something simple.
Tasha:这个我做过好多遍
Tasha: I've made this many times.
Tasha:提拉米苏也做过好多遍
Tasha: I've also made tiramisu many times.
Tasha:这两个不会失败的
Tasha: These two won't fail.
Tasha:还买了一个专业的
Tasha: I even bought a professional one.
Jake:这蓝莓怎么这么丑啊
Jake: Why do these blueberries look so ugly?
Jake:哈哈哈什么呵呵
Jake: Hahaha, what do you mean "hehe"?
Jake:教师傅撕保鲜袋
Jake: The master chef is tearing the cling film.
Tasha:我我我好像学会了
Tasha: I think I've learned it.
Tasha:看你这样操作
Tasha: Look at you doing that
Jake:真的没有吗
Jake: Really nothing?
Lucia: 我好了
Lucia: I'm done
Jake:好嘞
Jake: Alright
Lucia: 谢谢
Lucia: Thanks
Tasha:你还记得吗
Tasha: Do you remember?
Tasha:那天我们明明一起把那个托
Tasha: That day we clearly put that tray
Jake:好
Jake: Okay
Tasha:盘削在这的结果就不见了
Tasha: The plate here and it just disappeared
Jake:这不合理啊
Jake: This doesn't make sense
Jake:我来打
Jake: I'll call
其他人：你拿这个打
Others: Use this to call
其他人:我不要这个
Others: I don't want this one
其他人:打打不开一点
Others: Can you open it a bit more?
Jake:真的
Jake: Really
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha
Lucia: 有人要去取快递吗
Lucia: Anyone going to pick up the package?
Jake:啊他可以现在单独去取吗
Jake: Ah, can he go pick it up by himself now?
Lucia: 他说他现在忙不过来
Lucia: He said he's too busy right now
Jake:那
Jake: Then
Lucia: 您能帮忙取一下吗
Lucia: Can you help pick it up?
Jake:他说让自己取是吧
Jake: He said to pick it up himself, right?
Jake:因为比较平
Jake: Because it's flat
Jake:对是吧多好解冻
Jake: Yes, right? It's easier to defrost
Tasha: 别到
Tasha: Don't
Jake:哎呀好冰啊
Jake: Ah, so cold
Tasha: 一二三四五六
Tasha: One, two, three, four, five, six
Tasha: 七八九十1112
Tasha: Seven, eight, nine, ten, eleven, twelve
Tasha: 好把拆开就行了
Tasha: Alright, just open it
Jake:哎呀好冰好冰
Jake: Ah, so cold, so cold
Jake:不行了不行了不行了不行了不行了
Jake: I can't take it, can't take it, can't take it
Jake:冻坏了冻坏了
Jake: It's freezing, it's freezing
其他人:好冰
Others: So cold
Jake:就是蛋挞皮放我手上
Jake: Just the tart crust in my hand
Jake:蛋挞放在了外边
Jake: The tart was left outside
Lucia: 嗯
Lucia: Yeah
Lucia: 而且他说他申通那个取了
Lucia: And he said he picked up the Shentong one
Lucia: 但是就没有啊
Lucia: But it wasn't there
Lucia: 奇怪
Lucia: Weird
Lucia: 哪个啊
Lucia: Which one?
Lucia: 我刚看过了
Lucia: I just looked.
Lucia: 没有他说他神通那个取了但是
Lucia: He said he picked it up, but...
Lucia: 但是我觉得他我觉得他没取
Lucia: But I don't think he did.
Lucia: 你看啊就是
Lucia: Look, it's just...
其他人：手机上显示
Others: It shows on the phone.
Lucia: 这个
Lucia: This.
Lucia: 然后他说圆通和这几这三个都是
Lucia: Then he said YTO and these three...
其他人：哪一个
Others: Which one?
其他人：都没有啊
Others: None of them.
Lucia: 对然后这个我觉得他也没取
Lucia: Right, and I think he didn't pick this up either.
Lucia: 他是
Lucia: He is...
Lucia: 他好像是说这个他取了还是怎么啊
Lucia: He said he picked this up, or something like that.
Lucia: 不他是说另外的那个他取了
Lucia: No, he said he picked up the other one.
Lucia: 等一下我直接开淘宝看
Lucia: Wait, I'll just check Taobao directly.
Lucia: 对他说这个他取了
Lucia: Yeah, he said he picked this up.
Lucia: 但是其实就是我也没找到
Lucia: But actually, I couldn't find it either.
Lucia: 然后这几个他都没取应该
Lucia: And he didn't pick up these few either, I think.
Lucia: 菜鸟驿站和星辰分布还是什么意思
Lucia: What's with Cainiao Station and Xingchen Distribution?
其他人：是取外卖去了
Others: He went to pick up takeout.
Lucia: 也行你取外卖的时候可以叫我一下
Lucia: Fine, next time you pick up takeout, call me.
Lucia: 那他那个申通那个来
Lucia: So that Shentong one...
Lucia: 那是我的桌布啊烦死了
Lucia: That's my tablecloth, so annoying.
Alice:小什么
Alice: Little what?
Lucia: 皮面抽纸盒
Lucia: Leather tissue box.
Lucia: 难道呢是不是
Lucia: Really, isn't it?
其他人:多亏我话我觉得AI那不机器还非常好
Others: Luckily, I think the AI machine is really good.
其他人：你们还要不要打火机啊
Others: Do you guys still need a lighter?
其他人:对其实蛋挞里也可以随便加了
Others: Actually, you can add anything to the egg tart.
Tasha:蛋挞上面应该随便加8的蛋挞
Tasha: You should add anything to the egg tart.
其他人:蛋挞不会只有一人一个吧
Others: There won't be just one egg tart per person, right?
其他人:还真一人
Others: Actually, there is one per person.
Tasha:12个
Tasha: 12 of them.
其他人:差不多一个
Others: Pretty much one each.
Tasha:一人吃一个还不够吗
Tasha: One each isn't enough?
其他人:我不够行
Others: Not enough for me.
Jake:呵呵呵
Jake: Haha.
Jake:剩下8个人分两个呵呵
Jake: The remaining 8 people share two, haha.
Tasha:你真想吃的话咱们就烤24个
Tasha: If you really want to eat, we can bake 24.
Jake:呵呵
Jake: Haha.
Jake:呵呵是
Jake: Haha, yes.
Jake:所以为什么呢
Jake: So why is that?
Jake:为什么不填他就最高评价了
Jake: Why does not filling it in give him the highest rating?
其他人:很不甜比较健康
Others: It's not very sweet, so it's healthier.
Lucia: 好怪啊
Lucia: That's so strange.
其他人:比较健康
Others: It's healthier.
Jake:那为什么不吃草
Jake: Then why not just eat grass?
Jake:好我收回我的话
Jake: Alright, I take back what I said.
Alice:雨轩你有没有买一个地毯绿色的
Alice: Yuxuan, did you buy a green carpet?
Alice:我好像把你的拆错了
Alice: I think I opened the wrong package.
Alice:但是我你叫什么
Alice: But what's your name again?
Alice:就是你是小叉吗
Alice: Are you Xiaocha?
Alice:啊就是你的
Alice: Ah, it's yours.
Alice:呃收件名
Alice: Uh, the recipient's name.
Alice:那我是
Alice: So I'm...
Jake:杨鑫鑫是吧
Jake: Yang Xinxin, right?
其他人：杨欣欣
Others: Yang Xinxin.
Jake:就是那个
Jake: That's the one.
其他人：绿杨欣欣
Others: Green Yang Xinxin.
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Lucia: 我靠我要爆粗口了
Lucia: Damn, I'm about to swear.
Alice:我把那个地毯给你
Alice: I'll give you that carpet.
Alice:我说怎么感觉好像跟我印象不太一样
Alice: I was wondering why it didn't look familiar.
Lucia: 他那几个肯定没取上
Lucia: He probably didn't get those.
Lucia: 然后他非
Lucia: And then he insisted...
Lucia: 跟我说申通这他取了
Lucia: He insisted that he got it from Shentong.
Lucia: 问题这也没有啊
Lucia: But it's not here either.
Lucia: 然后那几个他也没取上
Lucia: And he didn't get those either.
Lucia: 然后他非
Lucia: And then he insisted...
Lucia: 说是然后他非说是驿站弄错了
Lucia: He insisted it was the station's mistake.
其他人:公费娃娃
Others: Public expense dolls.
Jake:公费娃娃
Jake: Public expense dolls.
Jake:不知道
Jake: I don't know.
Lucia: 嗯
Lucia: Hmm.
Jake:挂着然后我再改版改版
Jake: I'll hang it up and then I'll revise it, revise it.
Jake:没有没啥有
Jake: No, there's nothing useful.
Jake:用的东西
Jake: Nothing useful.
Lucia: 三卷好像
Lucia: Three rolls, it seems.
Lucia: 这好像也不是我吧
Lucia: This doesn't seem to be mine either.
Jake:我再改吧我再改改
Jake: I'll revise it again, I'll revise it.
Lucia: 我也觉得
Lucia: I think so too.
其他人：一个都没有解释什么
Others: No one explained anything.
Lucia: 对啊
Lucia: Yeah.
Lucia: 我要爆粗了
Lucia: I'm gonna swear.
其他人：我靠我们直接去对线
Others: Damn, let's go directly.
Jake:走我们去
Jake: Let's go.
Alice:这个是你买的吧
Alice: Did you buy this?
Jake:我们直接去驿站
Jake: We're going straight to the station.
Alice:哎
Alice: Hey.
其他人：哎哎我
Others: Hey, hey, I...
Jake:没有小车
Jake: No small carts.
Jake:你得走去
Jake: You have to walk.
其他人:草那也可以
Others: Damn, that's fine too.
Jake:可以啊
Jake: Yeah, it's fine.
其他人:可以啊那怎么没有小车
其他人:等一会拿麦当劳的时候一起
Others: Let's wait and get McDonald's together.
Lucia: 这俩是不是不在一个地方啊
Lucia: Are these two places different?
Lucia: 好像一个在菜鸟驿站一个在
Lucia: Seems like one is at the rookie station, the other...
Jake:有他们对
Jake: Yeah, they are.
Jake:他们有几个地方
Jake: They have several places.
Jake:但确实
Jake: But indeed...
Alice:啊你
Alice: Ah, you...
Alice:这个是你买的吧
Alice: Did you buy this?
Jake:哎对啊
Jake: Yeah, right.
Jake:问问问问
Jake: Ask, ask, ask.
Jake:这个师傅那跑腿
Jake: Ask the delivery guy.
Alice:不好意思
Alice: Sorry.
Jake:咱找咱们还是没找
Jake: Did we find it or not?
Lucia: 这胶带看起来很像我的
Lucia: This tape looks like mine.
Lucia: 但他名字不是我
Lucia: But the name isn't mine.
Lucia: 所以我认为应该也不是
Lucia: So I think it shouldn't be.
Lucia: 我不知道小什么什么
Lucia: I don't know Xiao what what...
Lucia: 我写的都是朱先生啊
Lucia: I wrote Mr. Zhu.
Jake:小
Jake: Xiao...
Jake:哪一个
Jake: Which one?
Lucia: 对绝对没错
Lucia: Yeah, definitely.
Lucia: 我都是猪先生
Lucia: I wrote Mr. Pig.
Jake:张
Jake: Zhang.
Jake:哦你已经分好了
Jake: Oh, you already sorted it out.
Jake:什么隐
Jake: What hidden...
其他人:就是我记不记得这个道路上全都是隐
Other: I was like, do I remember this road being full of...
Jake:哦哦哦哦
Jake: Oh, oh, oh, oh.
Jake:搞笑
Jake: So funny.
其他人:我草这个QQ你觉得屌不屌
Other: Damn, do you think this QQ is cool or not?
其他人:你平时走路掉很多线
Other: You usually drop a lot of connections while walking.
其他人:为什么定位到地铁口
Other: Why is it located at the subway entrance?
Lucia: 为什么你背后
Lucia: Why is it behind you?
其他人:打个场击不用
Other: No need to make a scene.
其他人：背后怎么了
Other: What's behind?
Lucia: 不是这不是
Lucia: No, this isn't...
Lucia: 是他贴的还是你帮他贴的
Lucia: Did he stick it on, or did you help him?
Lucia: 我是不是
Lucia: Am I...
其他人:啊没关系啊
Other: Oh, it's okay.
Lucia: 啊哈哈哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha!
其他人:不知道
Other: Don't know.
其他人:感觉只有修硕能干出来这种事情
Other: Feels like only Shure could do something like this.
Lucia: 哈
Lucia: Ha.
Jake:行吧几个场面
Jake: Alright, a few scenes.
其他人：哦我是你的了
Other: Oh, I'm yours now.
Jake:你是你是
Jake: You are, you are.
其他人:181818
Other: 181818.
其他人:记住丢烟头
Other: Remember to throw away cigarette butts.
Jake:哈哈哈傻屌
Jake: Haha, idiot.
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahahahaha!
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Lucia: 你不说可能还没人录到这个细节
Lucia: If you hadn't mentioned it, no one might have recorded this detail.
其他人：：不是我在做
Other: It's not me doing it.
其他人：你看还有这个处理视频时候逻辑
Other: Look, there's also this logic when processing videos.
Lucia: 哈哈哈神经
Lucia: Haha, crazy.
其他人：这个是意外
Other: This is an accident.
Jake:他他他对
Jake: He, he, he, yeah.
Jake:他傍晚时候要想洗澡
Jake: He wanted to take a shower in the evening.
Jake:然后他不知道二楼还在没关
Jake: And he didn't know the second floor wasn't closed yet.
其他人：洗头我就指着上面
Other: When washing his hair, I just pointed up.
Jake:对
Jake: Yes.
Jake:也就8个摄像头
Jake: Just 8 cameras.
Jake:哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahahahaha!
Lucia: 害怕了
Lucia: Scared now.
其他人：我昨天晚上早晨就有一个人
Other: Last night and this morning, there was someone...
其他人：吃完中间卡掉了哈哈
Others: After eating, the middle part got stuck, haha.
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahaha.
Alice:别把我的狗踢翻了
Alice: Don't kick over my dog.
其他人:不敢想象在这烧狗晚上得多丑
Others: Can't imagine how ugly it would be to roast a dog here at night.
其他人:哎我靠
Others: Oh my god.
Jake:烤了烤了3个小时
Jake: Roasted for 3 hours.
Jake:没没着火
Jake: Didn't catch fire.
Jake:哈哈哈后悔了
Jake: Hahaha, I regret it.
其他人:不敢想象在这烧烤得有多少在这烧
Others: Can't imagine how many times we grilled here.
Alice:在这烧烤
Alice: Grilling here.
Alice:手都快抡冒烟了
Alice: My hands are almost smoking.
Lucia: 不是那为啥还是欢迎欢迎
Lucia: Why is it still 'Welcome, welcome'?
Lucia: 我提亲啊
Lucia: I'm proposing.
Jake:因为这是最后一个
Jake: Because this is the last one.
Jake:我再给你们这群加上
Jake: I'll add more to this group.
Lucia: 太奇怪了
Lucia: That's so weird.
Lucia: 能把它关掉吗哈哈哈
Lucia: Can you turn it off? Hahaha.
Jake:哈哈哈我再加几个
Jake: Hahaha, I'll add a few more.
Jake:好吧让大家一起尴尬
Jake: Okay, let's make everyone awkward.
Lucia: 对对对大家全都加上去
Lucia: Yes, yes, add everyone.
Jake:好好好好欢迎欢迎
Jake: Okay, okay, welcome, welcome.
Lucia: 欢迎各位帝京
Lucia: Welcome, everyone from the capital.
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahaha.
Lucia: 这怎么关啊
Lucia: How do you turn this off?
Lucia: 太奇怪了
Lucia: That's so weird.
Jake:抵通可以可以
Jake: You can resist, it's okay.
Lucia: 快关一下
Lucia: Turn it off quickly.
Lucia: 杨老师快关一下
Lucia: Teacher Jake, turn it off quickly.
Jake:好的好的
Jake: Okay, okay.
其他人:坏了艾斯克尔又又过不了
Others: Oh no, Eskel can't make it again.
Jake:抵制什么呀
Jake: Resist what?
Jake:你要抵制什么呀哈哈哈
Jake: What are you going to resist? Hahaha.
其他人：不要再说
Others: Don't say it again.
其他人：再说s个人又又过不了
Others: If you keep talking, S person can't make it again.
其他人:再说我又要打打打款机了
Others: If you keep talking, I'll have to use the punching machine again.
Jake:呵呵呵
Jake: Hehehe.
Jake:加两个加两个
Jake: Add two, add two.
Jake:先加一个求数
Jake: Add one first.
Jake:就用你的这个
Jake: Use this one of yours.
Jake:你你你PPT里面那照片怎么样
Jake: How about the photo in your PPT?
Jake:你PPT
Jake: Your PPT.
其他人:打码的打码
Others: Blur it out, blur it out.
Jake:打码的
Jake: Blur it out.
Jake:哈哈
Jake: Haha.
Alice:可没送到
Alice: It wasn't delivered.
Lucia: 他有可能也拉下了
Lucia: He might have missed it.
Lucia: 他把我好多快递都拉下了
Lucia: He missed a lot of my packages.
Lucia: 然后他还非说他取了啊
Lucia: And he insists he picked them up.
Lucia: 哪个哪个女生
Lucia: Which girl?
Jake:他他不知道
Jake: He doesn't know.
Jake:群里不知道是什么人
Jake: Doesn't know who's in the group.
Lucia: 对群里不知道是
Lucia: Right, doesn't know.
其他人:我靠这是什么
Others: Oh my, what is this?
其他人:我靠这么帅
Others: Oh my, so handsome.
Lucia: 有一个申通他百分百没取
Lucia: There's a Shentong package he definitely didn't pick up.
Lucia: 无语子走
Lucia: I'm speechless, let's go.
Jake:走我们去取
Jake: Let's go pick it up.
其他人:走走let's go
Others: Let's go, let's go.
Lucia: 走走快
Lucia: Let's go, hurry.
Lucia: 不是快外卖来了吗
Lucia: Isn't the food delivery coming?
Jake:哈哈哈没有没有
Jake: Haha, no, no.
其他人:let's go
Others: Let's go.
Lucia: 那也可以先去取然后行
Lucia: We can pick it up first and then...
Jake:我问一下
Jake: I'll ask.
Jake:我先问一下
Jake: I'll ask first.
Alice:露西啊你的胶到了吗
Alice: Lucia, did your glue arrive?
Lucia: 我的胶他没给我取
Lucia: He didn't pick up my glue.
Lucia: 那个那个
Lucia: That one...
Alice:我这个胶不知道好使不好使点胶
Alice: I don't know if this glue works.
Lucia: 取快递的那个
Lucia: The one who picks up packages.
Alice:我去试试就这种
Alice: I'll try it, just like this.
Lucia: 什么叫
Lucia: What do you mean?
Lucia: 哦我们一会会去取
Lucia: Oh, we'll pick it up later.
Alice:哎我先试试这个能贴不能吧
Alice: I'll try if this sticks first.
Jake:嗯有跑腿是吧
Jake: Hmm, there's a runner, right?
Jake:那我们去取快递
Jake: Then we'll go pick up the package.
其他人：你是会装饰的哦
Others: You're good at decorating.
Lucia: 其他人：
Lucia: Others:
其他人：哈哈哈什么杰利凯特
Others: Haha, what's Jellycat?
其他人:我靠我一会要看看
Others: Oh my, I need to take a look later.
其他人:如果好如果好看的话我也要买一个
Other person: If it looks good, I want to buy one too.
Jake:走走走取快递去
Jake: Let's go, let's go pick up the package.
其他人:一一定一定
Other person: Yes, definitely, definitely.
其他人:一会要让我看那个小狐狸
Other person: Later, show me that little fox.
其他人:一定要让我看看
Other person: You definitely have to show me.
其他人:如果好看的话我买的快递都在这吗
Other person: If it's good, are all my packages here?
Lucia: 如果好看我买了个小鸟
Lucia: If it looks good, I bought a little bird.
Lucia: 啊
Lucia: Ah
其他人:啊不肯定不全
Other person: Ah, definitely not all of them.
其他人:应该不全
Other person: Probably not all.
Lucia: 不全肯百分百不全
Lucia: Not all, definitely not all.
其他人:你的手机上能看到哪些快递群
Other person: Can you see which packages are in the group on your phone?
Lucia: 全哎
Lucia: All of them, hey.
Lucia: 这好可爱
Lucia: This is so cute.
Jake:我试试
Jake: Let me try.
Lucia: 可可爱爱
Lucia: So, so cute.
其他人:像是我女朋友喜欢的东西这
Other person: This looks like something my girlfriend would like.
Jake:这摩的呵呵呵还挺可爱的这摩的
Jake: This scooter, haha, it's quite cute, this scooter.
Lucia: 这是干啥用的呀
Lucia: What's this used for?
Lucia: 哦
Lucia: Oh.
Lucia: 可爱真的很可爱
Lucia: Cute, really cute.
Jake:对摩的然后这个
Jake: Yeah, scooter, and this.
Jake:就
Jake: Just.
Jake:新加坡夜里面就有那个很大声音的
Jake: In Singapore at night, there's that loud noise.
Jake:那个摩的
Jake: That scooter.
Jake:对切了之后
Jake: Yeah, after cutting it.
Lucia: 我也要看
Lucia: I want to see too.
Jake:对然后换成他
Jake: Yeah, then change it to him.
Jake:就是给他配了个围巾
Jake: Just match it with a scarf.
Lucia: 这反正老板早晚要知道的
Lucia: The boss will know sooner or later anyway.
Jake:啥呀这个这是围巾啊
Jake: What? This? This is a scarf.
Jake:这是围巾啊
Jake: This is a scarf.
Lucia: 这围巾可爱
Lucia: This scarf is cute.
其他人:哈哈哈狐狸的价格你就别看了
Other person: Hahaha, don't look at the price of the fox.
其他人:反正也不是你出钱
Other person: Anyway, you're not paying.
Jake:哈哈哈我看看我看看
Jake: Hahaha, let me see, let me see.
其他人:那个狐狸我感觉得200200加一个围巾
Other person: That fox, I feel, costs 200, 200 plus a scarf.
Jake:我看看围巾是啥
Jake: Let me see what the scarf is.
其他人:一会先买家秀一下
Other person: Later, try it on first.
其他人:如果好我也买一个
Other person: If it's good, I'll buy one too.
其他人:卧槽这个这个
Others: Whoa, this, this
其他人:明天就是一个进货的阶段
Others: Tomorrow is just a stocking up phase.
Jake:对对明天
Jake: Yeah, yeah, tomorrow.
Jake:对是的
Jake: Yes, exactly.
Jake:明天每人带个眼镜
Jake: Everyone bring glasses tomorrow.
Jake:然后你们就对
Jake: And then you guys just...
Jake:好
Jake: Okay.
Jake:去拿去拿
Jake: Go get it, go get it.
Jake:走走咱俩咋去
Jake: Let's go, how are we going?
其他人:咱俩咋去
Others: How are we going?
Jake:走去
Jake: Let's go.
其他人:走过去很远
Others: It's a long walk.
Jake:那怎么办
Jake: Then what should we do?
其他人：有共享单车吗
Others: Are there shared bikes?
Lucia: 我看一眼那个京东应该是我的吧
Lucia: Let me check, that JD package should be mine, right?
Jake:开车方便去吗
Jake: Is it convenient to drive there?
Jake:跟牛帅说一下
Jake: Tell Nicous.
Jake:开牛帅车过去
Jake: Drive Nicous' car there.
Jake:咱没有走
Jake: We're not walking.
Jake:走大路走大路前点无法自拔
Jake: Take the main road, take the main road, can't stop.
其他人:沉迷甜点无法自拔
Others: Addicted to desserts, can't stop.
其他人:对啊
Others: Yeah.
Lucia: 啊哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Jake:我有20多个
Jake: I have more than 20.
Jake:没有我我这些东西很多的
Jake: No, I have a lot of these things.
Jake:麦当劳谢谢您
Jake: McDonald's, thank you.
其他人:那我们直接走推荐
Others: Let's just go directly.
Jake:驿站这谁
Jake: Who's at the station?
其他人:麦当劳就一公里还开车去麦
Others: McDonald's is just a kilometer away, and you're driving there?
Jake:没有没有
Jake: No, no.
Jake:咱是取快递
Jake: We're picking up a package.
Jake:咱是要取快递
Jake: We need to pick up a package.
Jake:走吧
Jake: Let's go.
Jake:确实这
Jake: Indeed this...
其他人:这谁贴的
Others: Who posted this?
其他人:不知道刘帅贴的吧
Others: Don't know, maybe Choiszt.
其他人:啥呀
Others: What?
其他人:不是我不一直在这呆着
Others: Not me, I've been here the whole time.
Jake:不是我贴的
Jake: It wasn't me.
Jake:不是你吗
Jake: It wasn't you?
其他人：真不是我
Others: It really wasn't me.
其他人：我操
Others: Damn it.
其他人：这个鸡蛋哥他妈一定要查出来啊
Others: We absolutely have to find out who this Egg Guy is.
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Jake:挖掘三尺
Jake: Dig three feet deep.
Lucia: 早知道早知道
Lucia: If I had known earlier.
Lucia: 我就不告诉你了
Lucia: I wouldn't have told you.
Lucia: 原来你不知道
Lucia: So you didn't know?
Lucia: 哈哈不知道
Lucia: Haha, you didn't know.
Jake:你你想想贴的时候戴没戴眼镜
Jake: Do you remember if you were wearing glasses when you posted it?
Shure: 我不知道谁贴的
Shure: I don't know who posted it.
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Jake:哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahahahahaha.
Lucia: 这个安康鱼也是你的吗
Lucia: Is this anglerfish also yours?
Jake:走走走哈哈哈
Jake: Let's go, let's go, hahaha.
Jake:那根线是谁的呀
Jake: Whose line is that?
Lucia: which one
Lucia: Which one?
Lucia: 啵啵啵啵
Lucia: Pop pop pop.
Jake:S1C04吗
Jake: Is it S1C04?
Jake:是吗你是C04吗
Jake: Is it? Are you C04?
Jake:是那就C04吧
Jake: If it is, then you're C04.
Jake:呵呵呵呵
Jake: Hehehe.
Jake:你是C01 C02啊
Jake: Are you C01 or C02?
Lucia: 啊哈那我可能是C04
Lucia: Ah, then I might be C04.
Jake:C03
Jake: C03.
Jake:他先扫的你后扫的你就是C04
Jake: He scanned first, you scanned later, so you're C04.
Lucia: 所以呢这个号有什么用吗
Lucia: So, what's the point of this number?
Jake:就是模型的代号啊
Jake: It's the model code.
Jake:是的模型3D
Jake: Yes, the 3D model.
Jake:就是你的那个
Jake: It's yours.
Jake:你你你当年的那个东西
Jake: The one you had back then.
其他人：少了个人吗
Others: Is there someone missing?
Jake:走发
Jake: Let's go.
Jake:个人
Jake: The person.
其他人：对少了我当年的人
Others: Yeah, we're missing someone from back then.
Jake:对
Jake: Right.
其他人:我觉得那个还是很很好用的
Others: I think that one was really useful.
Jake:是的
Jake: Yes.
其他人:虽然文件比较大
Others: Even though the file is quite large.
Jake:是的是的
Jake: Yes, yes.
其他人：高保真度的Max
Others: High-fidelity Max
Lucia: （歌词）强军目标召唤在前方
Lucia: (Lyrics) The goal of a strong army calls ahead
Jake:没有小车哎
Jake: There's no small car, huh?
Jake:问问可能
Jake: Maybe ask around
Jake:不是我们这个院子的
Jake: It's not from our yard
其他人：能不能载我们一球
Others: Can you give us a ride?
Jake:不是我们这院子的
Jake: It's not from our yard
Lucia: 咱这人有点多哈哈
Lucia: We've got quite a few people here haha
Jake:不是我们这院子的
Jake: It's not from our yard
Jake:试试试试问问
Jake: Try asking around
Jake:别走有步
Jake: Don't leave yet
Jake:您您是佑佑的院子吗
Jake: Are you from Youyou's yard?
Jake:我们想取快递啊
Jake: We want to pick up a package
其他人：咱们这个车
Others: Our car
其他人：现在我要去那个送东西用不了
Others: Now I need to use it to deliver something
Jake:啊
Jake: Ah
Jake:好
Jake: Okay
其他人：咱们那个按着那个导航
Others: We'll follow the navigation
其他人：然后那个咱自己取一下
Others: And then we'll pick it up ourselves
其他人：那个车也在拉东西
Others: That car is also transporting stuff
Jake:好我们能租
Jake: Okay, can we rent it?
Jake:嗯我们走吧
Jake: Hmm, let's go
Jake:哈哈哈摁f
Jake: Hahaha press F
Jake:F键
Jake: F key
Jake:哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahahahahaha
Lucia: 再见再见
Lucia: Goodbye, goodbye
Lucia: 哈哈哈啊一颗星
Lucia: Hahaha oh a star
Jake:哈哈偷我车是不会的吧
Jake: Haha stealing my car won't happen, right?
其他人:偷车在在洛洛洛圣都是不会机智
Others: Stealing cars in Los Santos is not smart
其他人:但在别的地方就不一定
Others: But elsewhere, who knows
Lucia: 什么GTA
Lucia: What, GTA?
其他人:感觉路上路
Others: Feels like on the road
Lucia: 路上哈哈哈
Lucia: On the road haha
其他人:我们如果只偷个车的话
Others: If we just steal a car
其他人:出一嗨再往从天上掉个坦克
Others: Go out, and then a tank falls from the sky
其他人:哈哈哈我记得有那个
Others: Hahaha I remember that
其他人:有一个什么暗语
Others: There's some kind of code
其他人:就是什么输一输一个英文单词
Others: Like you enter an English word
其他人:然后跟什么无伤跑的巨帅
Others: And then you run invincibly, looking super cool
其他人:子弹无限
Others: Infinite bullets
Jake:对哎
Jake: Yeah, right.
Jake:咱有导航吗
Jake: Do we have GPS?
Jake:哈哈哈傻子
Jake: Hahaha, idiot.
Jake:哈哈哈等会等会等会等会
Jake: Hahaha, wait, wait, wait, wait.
Jake:这真打GT啊
Jake: Are we really playing GT?
Jake:难走哈哈哈
Jake: It's hard to go, hahaha.
Lucia: 咱那群我怎么找不着啊
Lucia: How come I can't find our group?
Lucia: 找着了
Lucia: Found it.
Lucia: 先去菜鸟吗
Lucia: Shall we go to Cai Niao first?
其他人:我看飞机应该没什么吧
Others: I think there shouldn't be any issue with the plane, right?
Jake:你看飞机没什么
Jake: You think there's no issue with the plane?
Lucia: 菜鸟的话
Lucia: If it's about Cai Niao...
其他人:为什么谁知道的
Others: Why, who knows?
Jake:是啥呀对
Jake: What is it? Yeah.
Jake:透视哈
Jake: X-ray vision, huh?
Lucia: 如果说是那个菜鸟的话
Lucia: If we are talking about Cai Niao...
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Lucia: 好像是这个方向
Lucia: It seems like this direction.
Lucia: 然后这样然后这样然后这样然后这样
Lucia: And then like this, and then like this, and then like this, and then like this.
Lucia: 真不知道
Lucia: I really don't know.
其他人:好非常的形象
Others: Okay, that's very vivid.
Lucia: 哈哈形象对吧这形象
Lucia: Haha, vivid, right? It's vivid.
其他人:对非常形象
Others: Yes, very vivid.
Lucia: 对特别详细
Lucia: Yes, very detailed.
Lucia: 对它里面好像只发个菜鸟
Lucia: Yeah, it seems like it only sends a Cai Niao.
Lucia: 和一个别的什么
Lucia: And something else.
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahaha.
其他人:味太对了
Others: The taste is just right.
Jake:走走走要撞墙
Jake: Go, go, go, we're gonna hit the wall.
Lucia: 什么呀不要
Lucia: What? No way.
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahaha.
Lucia: 要有要一个人过来
Lucia: Someone needs to come over.
其他人:要有要一个人过来给你
Others: Someone needs to come over and give you...
Jake:哈哈哈嚯
Jake: Hahaha, oh.